-As a candidate,
Donald Trump repeatedly promised
that rural America,
which he dubbed Trump country,
would improve
under his presidency.
But is that really the case?
This is "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
Throughout his presidency,
Trump has consistently claimed
that now he's in charge,
everyone,
especially his supporters,
are coming out on top.
-America now is winning again.
Some people are getting
a little tired of winning.
The people of Missouri
are gonna go to your governor,
and they're gonna say,
"Governor, please,
go see the President.
We can't stand winning so much."
We are going to keep on winning.
We're going to win so much,
you're gonna get
so tired of winning.
Just so tired.
-I'll give him credit
for one thing.
He doesn't
overwhelm you with details.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I don't think he gets
how winning works.
You don't get tired of it.
I've never heard
a New England Patriots fan
burning his Tom Brady jersey
and moving to Cleveland.
"Enough's enough, Brady!
I got January plans!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump loves to say that,
thanks to this presidency,
farmers, coal miners,
and residents of red states
are back.
But in November,
"The Washington Post"
asked the question,
"Is Trump country
really better off under Trump?"
And their answer was no --
it's falling further behind.
And there's no better example
of that than West Virginia.
You might remember that
when Trump visited West Virginia
in 2016, he made all kinds
of impossible promises
and even
pretended to be a coal miner.
-I'll put it on, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've never seen someone
so proud of his ability
to put on and take off a hat.
[ Laughter ]
He took off that hat like a dove
was gonna fly out of it.
"Ta-da!"
Also, whoever picked
his hard-hat size
did not take into account
Trump's giant ego.
[ Laughter ]
I know next to nothing
about coal mining,
but I'm pretty sure
that's not how you do it.
Unless I'm wrong,
coal is generally not located
under 4 to 6 inches
of loose dirt on the surface.
I think he's mistaking
coal mining
with clearing the driveway
after a light snowstorm.
But Trump didn't just
act like a coal miner,
he also promised he'd put
coal miners back to work,
and as president,
he claimed he'd succeeded.
-It's really happening.
We are back.
The coal industry is back.
We've ended the war
on beautiful, clean coal.
I will tell you,
you will look back,
and you will say
it was the single greatest vote
you ever cast,
and you are gonna be very proud.
And for those miners, get ready,
because you're gonna be
working your asses off,
all right?
-So there you go.
Trump says he's ended
the war on coal
and that coal miners
would be
working their asses off,
but based on the actual facts,
it sounds like
their asses are still firmly on.
-Coal mines are closing
faster than ever.
-A bleak outlook tonight
on the coal industry.
A brand-new report from CNN
suggests more coal plants
have closed
during the first two years
of the Trump administration
than the first four years
of the Obama administration.
It's not because of regulations
but competition
with cleaner,
cheaper forms of energy.
Another 20 plants
are expected to close this year.
-In fairness,
it isn't Trump's fault
that the mines are closing.
It's just the march of time.
It's the same reason
it's hard to find work
as an abacus operator.
[ Laughter ]
And instead of facing
the reality that coal plants
are closing faster
under his presidency
than they did under Obama's,
Trump keeps
insulting coal miners
by insisting
that they're incapable
of doing anything
other than dig for coal.
-Remember, I was here
just before the election?
And I brought a couple of guys
into a room, and I said,
"Fellas, supposing
we teach you a new skill.
Supposing we teach you, like,
how to make little widgets
or gidgets or gadgets or...?"
These are big, strong
coal miners.
They said,
"Sir, we want to dig coal."
I said, "I agree with you!
I agree."
-Well, maybe they would've
answered differently
if you had said,
"We'd like to train you
to transition to another field
of energy development
that's cleaner and safer
with better
long-term prospects,"
instead of, "Do you fellas wanna
make widgets and gidgets?"
[ Laughter ]
"Giguh-guh-uhhh!
Wigi-gigi-guh."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, they told you they didn't
want to learn new skills?
Are you sure it wasn't
just an assumption you made
like you did in an interview
with "Playboy" magazine
back in 1990
when you proclaimed,
"If had been the son
of a coal miner,
I would've left the damn mines,
but most people
don't have the imagination
or whatever to leave their mine.
They don't have it."
Which is?
"'It' is an ability to become
an entrepreneur,
a great athlete, a great writer.
You're either
born with it or you're not."
And by "it,"
he, of course, means
a wealthy father
who cheated on his taxes.
[ Laughter ]
And don't take it from me.
Even experts on coal mining
in states like Pennsylvania
and West Virginia
said that Trump's lies
are actually hurting
the coal miners
he claims to be saving.
-He's lying to them.
-For 52 years,
Art Sullivan worked in
and consulted on mines
around the world.
And he bristles every time
he hears the President
claim to be the savior of coal.
-And that really disturbs me,
because these
are really good people.
-Do you feel the President gave
these communities false hope?
-In my opinion?
Absolutely.
I mean, I'm an expert.
He's not.
If you spend several years
working coal mines,
you're going to come
to understand electricity,
hydraulics, mechanics.
I see no limitation on
the average coal miner's ability
to transition
into any other field.
-That's right.
Coal miners are qualified
in electricity, hydraulics,
and mechanics.
Meanwhile, Trump isn't even
qualified to be the canary.
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump promised that cutting
regulations on power plants
would help bring back jobs
in rural America.
He also promised
that cutting those regulations
would not impact the quality
of the air and water.
-We want a clean environment.
We want a strong, beautiful,
clean environment.
I want clean air,
I want crystal-clean water.
And we've got it.
We've got the cleanest country
in the planet right now.
There's nobody cleaner than us.
And it's getting
better and better.
-Can we start
by cleaning you off first?
[ Laughter ]
You can't claim
we're the cleanest country
when the President looks like
he just lost a challenge
to eat the world's
hottest jalapeño pepper.
[ Laughter ]
"Don't worry --
my stomach can handle --
Oh!
I'm shvitzing right away."
So, there you go.
Coal mines might be
closing faster under Trump,
but at least they still have
clean air to breathe
and clean water to drink, right?
-The Environmental
Protection Agency
is considering rolling back
regulations on mercury.
It's a neurotoxin
that can lead to brain damage,
learning disabilities, and
other birth defects in children.
-The Environmental Protection
Agency announced
the proposal today,
saying that the cost
of these regulations
outweighs the health benefits.
Remind us again why we care
about mercury
getting into the air.
-It's a powerful neurotoxin.
There are also
other hazardous air pollutants
that are emitted
along with mercury.
-So you might have expected
Trump to neglect the blue states
that didn't vote for him.
I wouldn't be surprised
if he started dumping mercury
over New York
out of Air Force One.
"Don't breathe in, losers!"
But this is Trump country.
These are people
he promised to help,
and if this keeps up,
Trump might need a shovel
to dig himself out of this hole.
This has been "The Check In."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]